(en portugais)
- Lorsqu'il transmet l'écharpe
présidentielle à sa dauphine,izo
Lula Da Silva est le président
le plus populaire du monde.
C'est ce qu'a ditararararararar.
(applaudissements)
Après deux p p p p p p p p p pc
un taux d'approbation de 87 %.
Il a 65 ans et la constitution
ne lui permet pas de briguer
un tro
(sirène de police)
♪ ♪
Cet ancien ouvrier d'une usine
d'autos de Sao Paulo devenu
syndicaliste est né dans
une très dadadadadadadadadadada.
Il se présente quatre fois
à la présidence pour enfin
triompher en 2002.
♪
Sous sa direction, le Brésil d.
L'économie prospère,
30 millions de Brésiliens
sortent de la pauvreté
grâce à de généreuxiaiaiaiaiaia,
et le pays jouit d'un grand
prestige dans le monde.
Mais sa protégée,
Dilma Rousseff, n'est pas
à la hauteur quand l'économie
se d
destituée par le Congrès.
Le gouvernement du Parti
des travailleurs se retrouve
pris dans un gigantesque
éclabousse Lula, son fondateur.
Accusé de corruption, il fait
de la prison, et la justice
l'empêche de se présenter
aux élections de 2018
Puis, cette même justice
annule sa condamnation à 12 ans
de prison pour vice de forme.
Le Parti des travailleurs,
mais Lula, lui, rebondit.
EDMAR FAGUNDES DE ALMEIDA,
analyste politique
- C'est un des plus grandspopope
du Brésil. Après, il a
incarcéré... enfin, après,
son procès a été annulé,enenenee
quelqu'un qui...
qui a été... accusé
de façon injuste, disons.
(en portugais)
malgré ce qu'il a...
ce qui s'est passé
avec le PT... le PT,
tout le monde pensait
que le PT était mort.
- Lula et le PT ressuscitent aue
le président Jair Bolsonaro. Mat
un Brésil dangereusement
polarisé et une extrême
droite plus forte que prév
Les affaires de corruption
ont montré qu'une partie
rien savoir de Lula et du PT.
Une autre partie est rtététée
par les propos et les politiques
de Jair Bolsonaro.
dans les sondages, mais...- - -e
que Lula a, ce n'est pas
bon, c'est gagné. C'est...
Je pense que... Lula peut
gagner, oui, il est en avance,
les gens vont voter ou pas.
- À quelques jours du scrutin,
les sondages, qui ont bien
du mal à évaluer le rôle
ou blanc et l'abstention.
Ici Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, M